what is the best way to represent
integers yes it's the number line or the
number Ray what is a number line it's
simple it's just a line like this we
Mark the number zero in the center
towards the right we Mark all the
positive integers like 1 2 3 4 and so on
but wait they're not marked randomly
they are marked at equal intervals the
distance between any two consecutive
integers on a number line is always
equal on the left side of zero we Mark
the negative integers -1 -2 -3 minus 4
and so on at equal
intervals since the positive and
negative integers go on forever we Mark
arrows at the ends of a number line This
Arrow tells us that there are infinite
positive integers towards the right and
this Arrow tells us that there are
infinite negative integers towards the
left not only is this a good way to
represent the numbers on a number line
but this representation helps us in
inumerable ways we will see its uses in
the coming
[Music]
videos